you are looking at a live picture of
Capitol Hill where the final scheduled
public hearing of the January 6 assault
the the investigation into the January 6
assault took place inside and it took us
inside that terrible day when a mob
tried to overturn the will of the
American people welcome back to CBS
mornings the house select committee
relied heavily on video we'd never seen
before showing Congressional leaders
searching for anyone who could help
defend the capital this is Senate
Democratic leader Chuck Schumer calling
for protection
so I'm going to call up the effing
Secretary of DOD we have some Senators
who are still in their hideaways they
need massive Personnel now can you get
the Maryland National Guard to come to
hi Governor
CBS News Chief political analyst John
Dickerson joins us now for more uh John
good morning uh dramatic ending here to
the scheduled hearings and dramatic
ending to that hearing itself with the
uh unanimous vote to subpoena president
Trump what happens now
well the subpoena will president Trump's
not likely to testify of course and then
if the Republicans take control of the
house The subpoena goes away
um The subpoena and the questions about
it probably keep a little bit more focus
on this topic now that the hearing's
over
um but otherwise it's now just a matter
of debate and I guess part of what the
elections might be about although they
might not be about them at all what did
you make of the the video that we saw in
real time shot by the way by Nancy
Pelosi's daughter who's an award-winning
documentarian Alexandria who just
happened to be there and took out her
iPhone good on her to record all of that
but to see that in real time when they
seem to be working together John in that
moment well the first thing is that they
were scared well it also reminds us yes
it's an unguarded moment we don't get
unguarded moments with politicians every
one of those we've all talked to them
and we know what the freeze-dried answer
looks like right that was them searching
for anything that's one thing that was
interesting about the other is it
reminds us that what we all saw on that
day we all saw on that day there are a
lot of people out there trying and
convince us that January 6 didn't happen
that reminds us of just how panicked
things were and then finally they're
trying to find a solution to the
violence because at that time the
commander-in-chief who should have been
trying to find a solution to was not
only not trying to find a solution to
the violence but in fact was stoking it
yeah that was the moment when he knew
Mike Pence was under threat there's
Nancy Pelosi was on the phone to Mike
Pence the president knew Pence was under
threat and issued a tweet to make him
more the target of the rioters so it
gives us that contrast from that day
John I wanted to ask you about some
polls that showed people's opinion about
January 6 hasn't necessarily changed I'd
rather ask you does the work actually
matter
I think yes it matters videos
what we don't know is whether it matters
for good or bad okay I think it matters
because there's a lot of evidence that
we learned only through the committee's
work and that evidence came from
Republicans so it has validity and
weight if it matters for good people
will look at the heroes in this story
the people who stood up and did the
right thing that makes sense politics
like sports and journalism is a
storytelling business we sit around and
tell the stories about our heroes There
Were Heroes who stood up whether it was
the police officers uh or officials at
the justice department so if people in
public life who want to rise in life
look at those stories and say I want to
be a hero too then this was a platform
for heroism it also might send a lesson
that hey don't play footsie with people
who think who think you can use violence
when you lose an election because there
will be a bad outcome the bad way it
matters is whether a party has become
practiced in just making excuses whether
during this whole January 6 experience
because Donald Trump is still the leader
of the Republican Party Republican have
had to say this doesn't matter well if
you wave away this the the major threat
to the center of democracy if you can
get really uh used to waving that stuff
away then you can wave away anything
what did you make of the Secret Service
text we hadn't really heard about those
before Secret Service clearly knew that
we were in trouble or that something was
going to happen to at least 10 days
before the Secret Service techs give us
more data about another one of those
moments where Donald Trump had a choice
to either make things more violent or
make things more peaceful what we
learned from Cassidy Hutchins testimony
at the end of June was that the
president had been told there were
people with weapons at his rally and
that he waved them in said come into the
rally be a part of this group he knew
that that would make things more violent
and he said bring them in what the
Secret Service texts show is the Secret
Service who had warned the president
knew that things were violent knew that
there was the possibility ahead of time
ahead of time it's also obviously a
question for the Secret Service why
didn't you do more than you did you
seemed a little uh relaxed about this
imminent threat so that's their own
issue but on the central player of this
it's just more data that shows that in
fact the president did know and that in
the face of knowing he chose to make
things more violent rather than less
somebody who knows a lot about politics
John once told me history always gets to
bat last you know who said that I am
John Dickerson it was you John Dickerson
that's true that's because I said
someone who knows about politics our
only question is how long the game is
when that batting takes place John
Dickerson I always need a notepad to
take notes he's always sounds dropping
gyms today always thank you John thank
you thank you see you lecture night